hello everyone this is Elizabeth Norton
from a disaster information management
research center at the National Library
of Medicine today
we have a member of our own team who's
going to give a presentation
siobhan champ Blackwell who's a
technical information specialist slash
librarian in our disaster information
management research center he's going to
introduce the new online continuing
education classes related to disaster
health information these have been
enhanced and are now a self-paced type
mode and I think you're going to find
these greatly improved the classes are
part of our disaster information
specialist program which is designed to
help information professionals
librarians and disaster workforce and
any volunteers that support them to
enhance their skills as may be an
information responder and to learn how
to integrate the role of an information
specialist into the preparedness and
response efforts in your community or
even your organization she's also going
to talk about how you can get continuing
education credits for these classes and
if you're so inclined to go for a
certificate as a disaster information
specialist that is offered by the
Medical Library Association
so if Siobhan's ready I'm going to turn
this over to her all right remember if
you want a question please
type that in the chat box all right
thanks Elizabeth
so so we are really excited about these
classes just a little bit about turmeric
you know that it is our mission to
connect people to quality disaster
health information and and we've we've
done this by one one aspect of it is is
this disaster information specialist
program that we have and when we think
about who is a disaster information
specialist of course we think about
librarians
we are the National Library of Medicine
and we think about all librarians public
librarians are always are at the heart
of response in their communities but so
are special in medical librarians and we
think of members of the disaster
workforce because people in the disaster
workforce use information to make
decisions in the prepared you know in
the whole cycle in the preparedness
through the response and recovery
aspects of any kind of disaster
information is crucial to planning and
responding to events so one of the
things that when we were looking at
these developing these training
materials was to make them relevant for
members of the work disaster workforce
and for librarians and we looked at
information competencies so the Public
Health Foundation they've updated their
core competencies in 2014 and if you
look through through the competencies
you'll see retrieves evidence analyzes
evidence presents evidence evidence is
just constantly through those
competencies the National Center for
disaster medicine and public health also
has several competencies that include
understanding identifying sources for
information how to share that
information in strategic ways so so for
the disaster workforce these core
competencies exist and we've taken all
of these classes we've updated six of
them recently
into this new format and you can see
here that it's a wide range of courses
well I'm going to go online and show a
few examples of some of these courses
and how to access them in a minute but
you can see some of the different topic
areas that we cover in these courses and
as Elizabeth said you can get continuing
education we're going to go back to this
the C
the Medical Library Association survey
we've run into a little bit of a glitch
of course when you update things brand
new there's always something that you
didn't think about so one of the things
that we are working on is getting this
link to the Medical Library Association
survey added onto the class itself I'll
show you how you can find it on our on
our website we're also really excited
that our courses all of these courses
are listed in the Public Health
Foundation train learning management
system and they're connected with
competencies within train Elizabeth
talked about the Medical Library
Association disaster information
specialization certificate program but
Public Health Foundation train also has
some programs that they've developed and
some of our courses are incorporated
into those training plans so for example
the foundations of Public Health
preparedness includes our online class
on your digital go-bag so we're really
excited to be able to say that these
courses besides of course giving you
training that we think is relevant are
also are able to give you continuing
education and give you tools that you
can use in your professional life to
demonstrate that you're continually
learning and updating in your skill set
so I'm going to go online and I'm going
to show you the courses and how to
access them and get the credit also
we're going to have a couple of guest
speakers from the national network of
libraries of medicine and they're going
to talk about maybe some of the local is
you know where you're all scattered
around the country which is very
exciting for us and we're going to try
to put you in touch with some examples
of what might be going on within your
community that are ways for you to get
some local help as well as the resources
we provide through through NLM so let's
go online here
so what I'm going to do is just start at
our home page and so all you have to do
is know how to get to the disaster
information management Research Center
homepage and maybe Jen can put that link
into the chat box for you
so we've updated our home page in the
last couple of weeks to make it a little
bit simpler to find the information
about the specialist program and to make
it easier to find the courses I'm going
to start on the disaster information
specialist program and talk just a
little bit about that for just a second
so if I just click on that it brings you
into the information about the program
and this program what we're trying to do
is develop a network of people across
the country librarians members of the
disaster workforce who are all
interested in increasing their capacity
to respond with information before
during and after disasters and we do
that by these webinars and we have a
listserv and a online social media right
now we're on Twitter but we also then
have these training courses so if you go
into the disaster information
specialists program page you can get to
our training pages right there I'm just
going to go back to the home page for a
second and show you that also you can
access that same link right there so
this page is a joy for all of us now
because it's so much simpler to find the
courses and access them on this page you
can learn about the continuing education
courses and this is where you will find
let's see I can't see it this survey if
you once you're done with the class
you'll have to come back here to take
the MLA survey but you can see we have
the basic level in advanced level
courses if you anyone can just come on
here and take a class and get your you
can fill out the survey print out a
certificate and you're done or just
the class and increase your your
learning if you're interested and you
want to get the Medical Library
Association disaster information
specialization it is offered at two
levels the basic and the advanced and so
we list here what the suits the basic
level requires you to take these five
courses once you've done that you can
take 12 additional hours of any kind of
training that's related to disaster
health information including some of the
courses listed here or participating in
drills or any kind of activity if you're
a member of the Medical Reserve Corps or
your Community Emergency Response Teams
things like that you can fill out some
paperwork through the Medical Library
Association and you can submit all that
paperwork to MLA and get your
specialization so I will go ahead and
just pull up the MLA web page just to
show you see so you would click on this
page and it would provide you with very
similar information but here's the
information on how to complete the
application if you're interested in the
specialization that's a bonus we you
know we're excited to see people get
that specialization but again we're
really putting these courses together
for your to enhance help you enhance
your skills so what I'm going to do
right now you know I feel like we need a
drumroll you've been leading up to this
moment I'm just going to go ahead and
click right here on the basics course
and it rightaway opens up into the
course itself and so of the six courses
that we've updated five of them will
follow this format you'll come to an
introductory page on the left-hand side
of every page is the table of contents
of that page up here on the right hand
side is the menu and so when I
look here I can see that there are eight
modules in the basics course and so I
can navigate through these modules or I
can read through course which is what
I'm going to do read through the course
every page has the learning objectives
prove the introductory page provides the
information on how to get around the
course and what we want everyone please
to start by taking the evaluation the
evaluation is very short it's really
just what you already know you see how
how short that is five questions five
quick questions this is really helpful
for us to know when someone takes one of
these courses where do they start and at
the end you'll fill out a post
evaluation where did you finish and so
it helps us to evaluate whether or not
the course met the objectives that we
designed for it or do we need to make
some tweaks on it so we appreciate that
you take a minute or two to take that
evaluation and now I can just go here to
the next page and I'm on the course so
there's a couple of things that are
built into these courses as you see
along the table of contents here I've
got the topics that are covered by this
page but every page will also end in a
key point section so a summary of what
happened on you know what did we just
talk about just a kind of a quick
reminder of what what we covered on that
page and I'm going to actually go to
section 3 I'll show you how to navigate
and on section 3 I thought it was
section 3 maybe I need to complexion up
yes it is
I had there's a section called you try
it and so we've incorporated these
interactive scenarios into the courses
as well
so you know if you've been if you've
been paying attention now I cut them
along here and I have a question if I
wanted to find lessons learned documents
where would I go and I can click on this
and oh no that's not it
and it actually does tell me I'll leave
this one up a little bit longer it does
tell me the correct answer is both so if
I click on this yes and so what we were
really excited about these courses
because there the content is up to date
but it's also the self-paced kind of
course where where it's more interesting
than just the than our original format
which you know in the day that's what we
had we had our webinars that were
recorded but now this content is fresh
and new and interesting and interactive
I'm going to go to the conclusion of
this course and you can see again we've
got some test your knowledge and these
are not you know this is this is all of
this is four-year learning we're not
keeping track of this they're not tests
it's really you know if you got
something wrong and you want to you
might want to review the page what why
did I not get that one right you can see
we've got a lot of additional resources
on here and then we've got the post
course evaluation which is you know
again a few more questions than the
pretest but again we really appreciate
the fact that you're going to give us
feedback on these courses now now you're
done you've taken this course if you're
if you want to take the MLA seee
you come back here and there's the
evaluation link which is right here
and then I would select disaster
information the basics and it will pull
up the survey for me from the Medical
Library Association and once I'm done
with that survey the certificate for the
course will pop up and I can fill in my
name and I have a copy of the
certificate for my personal records and
also to send into the Medical Library
Association if I decide to go after the
specialization so that's the basics
course the basics course the US response
and information rules are all organized
with that same format there's two fema
courses as well and if you complete
those five courses you can you can file
for the paperwork for this disaster
information basic level certification in
the advanced level we've updated we've
updated a seat at the table and health
and disasters understanding the
international context again those are
the same kind of self-paced online
learning
now the severity chemical biological
radiological nuclear and explosives
health information resources course is a
little bit different because these have
six modules that are recordings so they
are narrated so when we come to this
website - when we click on that course
we come to a webpage and I can start but
I can click the introductions welcome to
health information resources for
subversion subversion stands for
chemical biological radiological now I
don't think that you can really hear the
audio on this there is closed captioning
and there's a table of contents so if I
want to so I can click here it'll start
this course by reviewing super
concepts and and then I can get rid of
this I forgot here get rid of it here so
again I've got the ability to navigate
through even then even through this kind
of video
narrated video and I can see the the
captioning so when I'm done with this
module I've still got this page open and
I can open module two when I come to the
end I go to the table of contents and I
believe that thank you for completing
this course we hope it is helped expand
your understanding of the Burnie
incident and how abiders cam and lens
can help plan for and respond to them so
right here when I'm done with this I've
got the link for for both the MLA survey
and for our post our post evaluation so
it's a little bit different the the
modules are again really interesting
they're probably I think they're between
three to eight minutes long I so you can
sit down and do them you know one a day
or you can do them all I think in about
an hour and a half is what it would take
you to do the entire module so we are
really excited about all of these
courses and we hope that you find time
to start taking some of them and that
they're interesting for you so Jen were
there any questions that came up while I
was I mean I saw you typing away madly
over there but was there anything that I
needed to address yes
George and I'm asked is do we have any
shortcut to do the sign-in she took a
class and realized that she has to be
signed in to get the credit so we have
changed everything
now the way to get the credit is to take
the MLA survey so if you've already
taken the course all you have to do is
go to that survey page and click on the
course that you took and fill out the
survey we had a learning week they are
listed also on a learning management
system and we'll send out the link to
that learning management system and I'm
assuming that that's what you did
initially that you logged in to the
learning management system but this is
now kind of a shortcut to just save you
from one more login Genpact you our
assistant here who is also a member of
our professional team at the disaster
information management Research Center
she's going to put the link in again to
the page that has the link to the
evaluation survey which will then take
you to your MLA certificate it's on the
training resources page and if you go
there even if you've already taken it
through our prior system you can click
on that page and I think they're
actually going to show that as well you
can see where it says evaluation survey
and if you click on that you'll see that
it takes you to the U to the C e survey
and you can click the course that you
took and then go from there and it will
ultimate you'll get to your certificate
and in fact this is if you're on this
course and you want one hour see e for
today this is the same place you go so
you can see we list the monthly
conference call so if I click on that
and I hit next then then the send the
questions to start start coming up and I
get to the MLA CD so it's pretty simple
to do you just have to remember that you
have to start on this page to get to
that C e to the C T survey okay and then
another question from Jennifer Johnson
I'm not sure
we'll be covered or not but for the
specialist it mentions that the
requirements participants have three
years together and contact the contact
hours needed to apply with
specialization is there a link that
provides more information about this
okay so on this page the specialization
is through the Medical Library
Association and so this is the this is
how you would so that's off the training
page you can find out information about
the disaster information specialization
that the Medical Library Association
provides so it's very similar to looking
through our pages all of these classes
are listed and linked just like ours due
to the course themselves if I clicked on
this it's going to take me to that
basics course that we just looked at and
then it has the the way that you apply
so so the most important thing for
applying for the specialization is
keeping track of those certificates so
once you once you fill in the
certificate you know you can save the
PDF file to a folder you can print it
out and have it in print form however is
easiest for you to manage the paperwork
behind it and then there's just an
application form here from the Medical
Library Association that you fill out
for members of the Medical Library
Association it's $55 and for non-members
of $75 so it's just a it's just a
process filing paperwork with MLA and I
think there was a psyche on that right
that's another follow up comment from
Jennifer says that is the page with the
comment about the contact hour so I
think that she did if I'm correct you
went to this page and it says you have a
year to gather and is there more
information about that am I correct I
think that's what that means is that
over the course of you know when you
send in the certificates you have to
have taken they have to be dated within
the
course of whatever that timeframe is so
if you take a basics course now and four
years from now you take another course
you can't use the basics course from
this year to apply for that application
so it's really talking about the time
period that you have to take the courses
in because we want people to stay
current so which is also why we updated
the courses so we're wanting to make
sure that you're taking the that you
have access to the most recent
information and training in order to get
this specialization and if that didn't
answer your question let us know and
also we can put in an email address at
the end of in the chat box you can put
in my email if you know it the longest
one and you can email me okay anybody
well this is the end of Siobhan's
presentation and before we move to talk
to the national network of librarian
individuals I just want to check to see
if anybody else has any other questions
they would like to put in the chat box
and if you've taken any of the new
classes we'd also like to know what you
think of them and if you think this
format is you know is user friendly and
maintains your interest so if anybody
has taken those or if you've taken it in
the previous four previous format we'd
love it if you would try one in the new
format and just let us know what you
think one of the original developers of
one of the classes I saw Robin
Featherstone who helped us get started
with this whole program said she thinks
the new format looks great and we are
certainly appreciative of all her
efforts of beginning this whole she
introduced to us two classes the basics
of the information role so we took what
she did and we had that updated and put
into this type of format so we really
want to give her some kudos for starting
these classes I'm going to say that
because actually I can't see the list of
participants that I know so many of the
we let the course developers and
and several of them said they were going
to be on the call so John Scott and Pat
Bittner right so I guess that we should
be thanking all of the original course
developers for taking the time to
develop these courses and put together
just so much information that's been
very critical to us even having this
disaster information specialist program
so it was very essential components and
is extremely grateful for their efforts
yeah okay all right well someone George
Ann said she's taking a class and the
format is great so we'll take that great
thanks for comment thank you
all right Siobhan do you wanna yeah so
I'm going to start with Michelle Berta
from the national network of libraries
of Medicine mid-atlantic region for
those of you who don't know about the
NLM just go to an NL m dot gov on your
website and you can see a map of the
regions to find out which region you
would be in because what what happens
with the regional medical libraries is
it's it's like there's eight little mini
national libraries of medicine out in
the world and you find out where your
regional medical library is and they
have face-to-face training and
exhibiting and all kinds of resources
for you
so Michelle we have to unmute Michelle
somebody else can talk while I'm doing
this Elizabeth yeah you don't have
anything to say no I just encourage
everybody to go and check out to these
training courses and just also we're in
the process of redoing our entire
website cleaning it up making it a
little more streamlined a little more
contemporary a lot easier to find things
and that's going to be occurring I'm
going to say over the next six months or
maybe a little more take the whole time
into this and it should be much easier
to find the important information that
you might need as a disaster information
specialist or someone just looking for
disaster health
so we're excited about doing that and
when we are finished with that we'll
probably bring that up again on another
webinar and show people how to navigate
around the new site but does redesigning
these training courses was the first
step in trying to maybe update some of
our our content and the way you can get
information so I'd miss out on how are
you there
yes I am ok we can hear you so go ahead
ok as Siobhan said I am one of the
coordinators and with the Middle
Atlantic region and my official title is
education and health literacy
coordinator so one of the programs we
are currently working on is we are in
partnership with a Delaware division of
libraries and the University of Delaware
and also the Delaware disaster Research
Center and what we are doing now we're
planning a one day long symposium to
connect the library staff with emergency
planners to help communities bounce back
more quickly following a natural or
man-made disaster and the focus of this
we're calling it a summit the focus is
on developing partnerships and
strategies before an emergency happens
so also one of the components will be
that I will be talking about the
National Library of Medicine resources
like MEDLINE plus and focus and the
focus will be on the health and disaster
information resources and also the
timmreck resources so that's the part
that I will be doing and one of the
other things we're going to do is
explore what it means for a library to
be a second responder in their
respective emergency planning and patron
communities our summit and we hope will
be of interest to emergency planners
first responders librarians and
organizations involved with disaster
planning response and recovery and
I thought it might be of interest to you
to just tell you a couple of the things
we have on the agenda and who those
speakers will be we reached out to Susan
Quinn who she was involved with her with
the superstorm sandy she is the Ocean
County librarian and director of the
Ocean County Library and she is very
much involved with the Ocean County
emergency planners the mayor's office
and and the facilities managers in her
community so she will be speaking to the
group on some of the things they've done
and their involvement during during this
time so she will talk about what they've
done before to lay the groundwork and
then after and then we're also planning
on the afternoon we'll have a panel
discussion in the morning also with our
emergency planners and these will be the
county coordinators and emergency
responders from the three counties in
Delaware and because Delaware is so
small it's it was an easy group to work
with like I said because there's only
three counties Dan Wilson who was a
specialist in disaster planning for
libraries and you may know of him he's
done many of these type of summits
before all around the country he will
kind of be our coordinator and emcee for
the day and he'll be conducting the
panel then in the afternoon what we hope
to do is the people who have come from
our libraries than anybody else will be
broken up into groups in their
respective counties so we hope that
there's a representative from the
emergency responders for each County and
then the librarians
these responders will have a have
conversation and time to explore their
goals and and what the library's can do
and then this also gives exposure to the
emergency responders about what a
library can do for them other than just
being a gathering place what the skills
are of the librarians so that's kind of
our day again it was it's going to be a
Dover Downs in Delaware February 28th
it's not open to the public this is
mostly our librarians first responders
those type of and community planners so
that that's what the event will be like
and I do invite any of you if you are
close to that Delaware line or you know
you are willing to travel and maybe this
is of a special interest to you and want
to see how the event um is conducted and
you want to and you may be interested in
planning something like this in your
organization or in your state we welcome
you there is no cost for registration so
that's all I have anybody have any
questions for me I'm happy to answer
those or you can email me at em bu RDA
at Pitt P ITT edu thanks okay Thank You
Jaclyn do you want to share your screen
we're going to have Jaclyn from the
national network of libraries of
medicine greater Midwest region next oh
I need to unmute you do you want to
share it if you want okay you want to
share the screen I tie you down put two
links in the chat window for you if you
like just to bring those two pages up
and I think we'll be fine
and you want to start with the advisory
group first release it okay there you go
thank you Siobhan and those of you at
the best disaster information management
Resource Center for inviting me today to
talk about the initiatives that we have
in the greater Midwest region as fun
said we
one of eight regions across the United
States who make up the national network
of libraries of medicine my colleague
Michelle and I have been with the
network for a number of years and with
just with this May first we started in a
new five-year grant period prior to that
we had a five-year period where the
national network had an actual emergency
preparedness initiative dan Wilson as
Michelle said was the leader of that
group well we don't have that same
initiative this time going around but
one of the things that the GMR office
wanted to do was to strengthen than the
national network emergency preparedness
and response plan within our region so
in order to avoid or limit as much the
interruption and access to information
throughout the region and nationally
during those emergencies and disasters
we also wanted to engage more of our
network members actively and effectively
in participating in an alum probe and
NLM programs and so with that we created
a number of advisory groups and if you
scroll down to the bottom of that page
you can see that we have a working group
called disaster health information
coordinators this is a new initiative we
have one member from every state except
we're still working on South Dakota in
our 10 state region here in the GMR who
has volunteered to become one of our
disaster health information coordinators
and we're really not even sure yet at
this point if that's what we're going to
call our group because we're still in
formation right now I actually we are
using today's webinars being a
springboard for the work that we're
going to do together one of the
advantages of becoming a disaster health
information coordinator within the GMR
is that the GMR is going to fund the
registration process for becoming a
health disaster health information is
specialists through MLA so that's one of
the perks of this not only for the
individuals but for all of us in the
region because we will have specialists
on hand locally and increase the
capacity within our region for emergency
preparedness would you like to go to the
next page come on yes thank you one of
one of the other funding mechanisms that
we have put together for emergency
preparedness in the GMR is an emergency
preparedness award and this award is
actually following the New Jersey
initiative that developed after
Hurricane sandy
just as the just as the national network
emergency preparedness initiative in the
previous contracts with NLM were based
basically on as a response to what
happened in Katrina at any event this
emergency preparedness award is one of
our funding mechanisms that fits in
basically with what we have designed
designed to be the aims of our
cooperative agreement with the National
Library of Medicine so basically this is
a way that we really want to get our
network members engaged involved and
strengthened in the emergency
preparedness and response plan so part
of our objectives with this are to Train
public library staff we also want to
increase the role of public libraries
but we're also considering engaging
state organization so it's not just
Public Library group but it's also
various groups within the state who may
be a consortium and who want to take a
stab at this and seeing if they can get
their communities at a place at the
table in emergency preparedness
we don't have any takers yet eligibility
is just two numbers in the GMR are 10
state region and we're hoping to have
the funding actually fund three
initiatives up to $10,000 through this
initial year of the grant that we have
with the National Library of Medicine
we're hoping that this funding mechanism
on the website is very straightforward
and if anybody has any questions within
our region about that or or elsewhere
I'd be very happy to talk with them
about that we may not get this on the
ground that the funding at least off the
ground this grant year but we definitely
will have our emergency preparedness
coordinators up and running and become
disaster information specialist thank
you all right well thank you Jacqueline
and thank you Michelle as well so so
each of the regions each of the eight
regions is working in some form or other
on disaster health information we didn't
have enough time to have everybody come
on and talk about it but I would I would
really advise people who are interested
in reaching out membership is for not
just librarians but people who work in
health information to reach out to your
Regional Medical Library and become a
member at free it's free and learn about
some of these disaster health
initiatives as well as other initiatives
that the regional medical libraries work
on special on if I am a emergency
manager or public health specialist in
my local health department can I contact
the National out of the regional library
of the national network absolutely you
can contact them and your organization
can become a mem
and and becoming a member provides you
access to many of the benefits that some
of these that Jacqueline and Michelle
were outlining in their talk today so
yes the the membership in Totten even if
you're not a member of course contact
them for health and assistance and and
one of the great things is the regional
medical libraries are in close contact
with medical and public libraries in
their states and so they can connect you
with even more local person so what you
know we always say disasters are local
so so through this this kind of chain
where we start with NLM kind of at the
national level and the regional medical
libraries at a regional level then they
can connect you to your local library
and and that's what we need with with
disaster response I know that we started
off everyone muted can you check and
make sure your phone is muted there's a
little bit of feedback on the call and
we're not sure where it's coming from
are there any other questions if we'll
keep the line open here for a little
while and if you have any questions
please feel free to put some of those in
there and also our contact information
you can reach any of us at tim ricke
vimrc
at NLM nih.gov and we'll put that in the
chat box as well and while I'm giving
people with chance to see if there's any
other questions or if anybody has a
comment they want to make please do put
that in there and we'll take a look I
just have two small announcements one
our next meeting it's scheduled for
February 9th
but we've been going more from a monthly
schedule to an every other month
schedule so it's possible we will not
have another one until March 9th so if
you are on our listserv or are not one
of our email distribution lists watch
for the announcement for the next
webinar
and also remember you can come back to
our website what's showing on the slide
actually here where it says the
recordings and slides will be added
online you can view this webinar on
there in about a week or so and all our
previous ones going back I believe to
two thousand and maybe nine or eight or
nine and remember you can get to see
Equus for those from the Medical Library
Association you get one credit hour for
each of these even if you're listening
to the recording all right so the last
announcement I want to make is a big big
transition for us one of the founders of
the disaster information management
Research Center retired at was November
December first was with somewhere in
there and that was Cindy love and I
think many of the people who are
involved in the national network of
libraries of medicine in any of the
medical libraries and also even in the
preparedness sector and response sector
may have known Cindy she was one of the
very first people getting involved in
this here at the we have somebody's on
hold I think and we're listening to some
music we're going to look for that and
see if we it stopped anyway
this is just a little tribute to Cindy
and you know we miss her and we're
hoping she'll still be able to do some
work with us in the future but she's
just enjoying her time off right now and
after 30 years I believe it was at the
National Library of Medicine I think she
deserves a break
it wasn't for Cindy and our and our
branch chief Stacey Arneson none of us
would really be here and this
information would it exist and be easy
to find and so we owe it to them and
Cindy guts gets her well-deserved break
but we do miss her so if there's no
other questions yeah on how long is this
certification good for oh I think it's
for three years okay yeah that might be
on the page that we already put up there
for
Medical Library Association disaster
information specialization but we think
it's four years as Shabaab just said and
then another question is where you see
disaster information trained librarians
fitting in with a Medical Reserve Corps
so that's a great one so one of our
courses is of course the information
rolls but you can become a member of the
Medical Reserve Corps and Stacey are you
a member of the Medical Reserve member
of MRC am a member of cert the community
emergency response team we don't have an
MRC in in our area okay I think Dan
Wilson is a member of the MRC you know
there's so many different things so many
information needs that everyone needs in
disaster response so for example one of
the one of the roles that really fits
perfectly what librarians do is
situational awareness and being out
there on social media and finding what's
going on in an area so if you're in part
of the Medical Reserve Corps and and
maybe use your following social media
and you see that a road is closed or you
see that there's people who need
assistance from the Medical Reserve
Corps in a certain area things like that
that situational awareness of pulling
together the information and organizing
it and presenting it to the Medical
Reserve Corps responder disaster
workforce in a way that they can use it
and make decisions on how to respond
it's just one small example of how a
person with the information
specialisation can use their skill set
to assist in in organizations like the
Medical Reserve Corps and there are
librarians who are members of reserves
for the reserve court has all kinds of
people who are members not just the
health care professionals all
organizations need that need information
and the
information professionals and another
way is to help them know ahead of time
about the various information resources
or that are out there so if they are
called in to something some of the
Medical Reserve Corps and do the
emergency response but sometimes they do
a bit more day-to-day activities that
could be vaccines or other kinds of
things but making sure that they know
where to get that information and have
it another area for example would be our
packing your digital go bag and we have
a page of disaster apps that many in a
disaster workforce we recommend that
they put on their phones and tablets
other mobile devices ahead of time and
learn how to use them and that's another
role where librarians could help them
get familiar with these tools and
resources and how to use them and when
and where they can be used for example
doing connectivity for them or can they
stand alone as the information residing
right on the device so those are a
couple of ways that you can assist with
your Medical Reserve Corps and I do
believe there are a couple of librarians
who are members of disaster medical
assistance teams d-mat teams that are
actually run out of the Department of
Health and Human Services in which case
of you are activated under d-mat you
become a temporary federal employee
during that time and there are a couple
of librarians that assist in in those
programs as well and I was corrected
that in my area there is an MRT I
believe it's relatively new so I
apologize to anybody in this area and
MRC alright
we do have another question on here and
it says from Patricia that says what
would you advise for me to do in my
first step complete the basic course and
then the advanced I would say definitely
start with the Texas basics course
itself so that is not just the basic
specialization but just go ahead and
take the basic course because that will
give you a really nice background and
one of the things is learning the
language of response and
Aster's so taking that basics course
gives you that and and then we'll give
you some information on what are the
things that out of that class that you
really liked so from there you might
decide you want to take the other
courses to get your your basic
specialization or you may say well I'm
more excited about some of these other
courses down here now one of the other
classes that we did mention is the
information roles in disaster management
I would also recommend that as another
good class to take initially it's listed
in the basics section that will help you
decide what kinds of roles you might be
able to play and it might steer your
interests in some of the other classes
that's a good point to you and here's
the topics that are covered in that
class now we're always looking to hear
from people about what what kinds of
things that they have done with their
communities in this in this subject area
so if you have any stories or anecdotes
or things that training courses you've
done or other kinds of things that
you've participated in we'd be happy to
hear about that actually people posted
and let other people know what kind of
roles they can play so it's a expanding
field yeah and if anybody is interested
in some of the ideas about how you can
interact with your community within
disaster health information I have two
other suggestions not only take these
classes but also we have a bibliography
a rather extensive bibliography
of articles and stories of how libraries
and librarians and information
professionals have worked in disasters
not just in their own libraries but in
their communities as well so we're
showing that page now and we can put
that link into the chat box and
I'll give Jen just a minute maybe to do
that and then the other way well it's
down at the bottom if you go to the
right if you go to this disaster
information specialist page it's right
now there's a link on the bibliography
page there alright and also for five
years and this is the first year we did
not do it but for five years we funded
with small contracts I believe it was
twenty something or 25 different
projects where libraries or librarians
or other information centers partnered
with a community organization that had
some disaster responsibilities and they
did projects where they would work
together and in some cases they
developed apps they work together to do
that in other cases they developed
webpages or they develop training
classes or they created a role on their
emergency response teams and a whole
host of things and we have a link to
those which link to that page where you
can read about what some of these
librarians and these organizations did
to work together so you might get some
ideas there about what can you do with
this disaster health information
specialist role and that link is coming
up there right now all right
and we'll put that in the chat box
so we are coming to the end of our time
here today and we appreciate everybody's
attention and their interest in this
topic and we're again if you are not on
our listserv or not on our email
distribution list you can do one of two
things you can go to our homepage and
look for the section on the left-hand
side that says stay connected and you
can also email us directly at dimmer ik
@ NL m dot nih gov and we will get back
to you about how to stay connected with
us so if there's not any other major
questions here or any other comments I
think we'll see if there's anything here
okay all right a few comments that we'll
take a look at nothing else all right
well everybody have a nice afternoon
and/or end of morning depending on where
you are and we'll let you know when our
next webinar will be and thanks again
Michelle and Jacqueline for your great
presentation all right well we're going
to walk off now thank you very much
bye-bye